I am presenting with mark hamill can't
even say is this a secret do you know
it's not it's you see how bad they've
got into my head I feel like every big
in a Star Wars so how has it been how
have you been I've been really good
really know just like you know what's
funny is everyone kind of says it's
gonna be one thing that your life is
gonna be insane
but I still go to Trader Joe's they
still run outside and it's totally okay
that's wonderful
you're presenting tonight yeah what
award representing um I am presenting
with Mark Hamill can't even say is this
a secret do you know it's not if you see
how bad they've got into my head I feel
like every bit in the Star Wars like a
reflex mark and I ever did a movie I
don't know if you saw today that the any
device of this left has shifted to the
Han Solo movie I don't know if you've
seen the trailer yet wonderful great yes
I've seen it yes I was so excited to see
it I'm so excited to see it I love
everyone that's in it I'm stoked yeah
amazing I'm very happy that you're not
on twitter.com because this is what we
do this is what we do all day on Twitter
Don I do stalk Twitter I've read some of
us I left some of your tweets oh just
okay cuz they're all nice girl fries
Kelly really may the force be with you
so um I want to talk about one thing
with rose that I loved the line at the
end there and then we've got the little
connection between Finn and Rose oh my
gosh they're in love
where would you like to see Rose go next
like if it were up to you you know what
I think it's really gonna depend on how
far of a time gap there is like I've
thought about that you know I'm like
thought about what I would want to see
but I also kind of just want to see what
JJ has up his sleeve I don't want to I'm
one of those people that doesn't like to
make any sort of expectation because I
like to kind of have it come to me in an
unbiased way so I'm excited to see but I
think we all kind of have the same that
same mentality I'm just like let's just
see what we have you know I think it's a
cool thing to to be able to kind of let
go and see what happens you go from
there and that's kind of my philosophy
and I'm excited to have that sort of
creative collaborative mess that
everything and sort of is and I'm
excited to do that again I think one of
the craziest things Ryan did was that he
inserted that Maz Kanata just hooks up
with everybody
I loved that so much she hooked up with
Justin Theroux I I liked that she also
was like in the middle of a battle and
just threw it out there studio actually
I'm like my girl
you